maintenant on va voir au caire
que je n'en ai sans toi mais bien au
chaud
merci pour lui vous méritez beaucoup
plus évidemment vous êtes le footballeur
français le plus titré
l'un des footballeurs mondiaux les plus
titrés aussi de ligue des champions l'om
en 93 la juventus 196 champion de france
90 92 champion d'italie 95 97 98 coupe
d'italie 95-97 coupe d'angleterre avec
chelsea en 2006 champion du monde en 98
champion d'europe en 2000 recordman des
sélections 103 matches avec les bleus et
recordman des matchs comme capitaine 53
sélections mais la mission
un triomphe en mars inscrit au format
atelier consécration ultime ici
c'est le top
merci à tous didier deschamps donc alors
le seul problème vous ai jamais eu la
coupe de france si jamais joué de finale
non la seule année où j'aurais pu la
jouer c'était malheureusement lors des
incidents de furiani soir et en demi
finale et donc je n'ai pas eu la chance
de jouer je me coupe de france non
bombay tournée prochain quelques années
encore de la garde d'un touche au plus
près alors désormais vous êtes
reconverti depuis que vous avez quitté
dans les produits laitiers les biskris
michel a dit que c'est mais le biscuit
ce module est aussi un vallon zoom jouer
à valence oui pourquoi valence pourquoi
être les jouer à valence pourrait pas en
france mais pour revenir en france il
faut être deux il faut que moi j'ai le
vague
ouais je le voulais mais bon il n'ya pas
des clubs qui ils ont voulu et donc
voilà l'annoncé difficile pour elle que
ce que c'est que cette histoire n'est
pas un club si vous avez vous lu j'ai eu
des contacts mais bon c'est difficile
avec un titre de champion du monde et
tout cela que ça représente vrai que
c'est pas c'est pas évident
pour les clubs français à l'heure
actuelle c'est pratiquement impossible
de refaire de faire revenir un
championnat mans alors vous êtes en plus
de sa consultant et animateur sur tps
dans une émission qui s'appelle des
champs contre champs balla et alors vous
avez quoi carte blanche pour parler de
foot c'est ça donc fait ce que vous lui
oui c'est un magazine entre 20 et 25
minutes toujours revient sur l'actualité
du football de la semaine et puis j'ai
un invité au téléphone pendant une
dizaine de minutes en général un joueur
ou un entraîneur puis quelques petits
retour sur la carrière ainsi le match en
équipe de france fut animateur québécois
oui un peu quand vous ça va l'uso un
site internet dont le numéro apparaît en
bas de l'écran alors c'est quoi ce site
c'est pour l'heure de vos nouvelles pour
way pour communiquer avec avec le public
et les fans je crois que ça permet de
répondre en direct à voir son contact un
peu plus proche et lorsqu'on est à
l'étranger
c'est moins évident que lorsqu'on joue
dans un club français donc ça permet
d'être toujours au courant de
l'actualité du jour bien alors on va
parler un petit peu de
alors dominique si des fois il dit pas
la vérité je compte sur vous pour
corriger un maintenant vous le
connaissez très très bien donc j'étais
en 68 à bayonne au pays basque jusque là
tout va bien dans un milieu ouvrier
votre merde travail de 7 heures du matin
à sept heures du soir comme vendeuse et
votre père il est peintre à l'aérodrome
de biarritz ils travaillaient les
samedis et dimanches
donc ça bossait beaucoup je vais
deschamps a raillé pour gagner un peu
plus d'argent il a voulu oublier la
maison voilà entre autres comme nous
tous
alors je manquais de rien mais pas de
superflu quoi oui ça vous a donné des
bonnes bases tous années certains
repères vous allez valeur les gens la
famille les valeurs familiales
l'homme du pays basque en fermant là
c'est assez carré comme mec quoi on peut
appeler ça comme ça mais peu un peu têtu
voix oui très justement comme vous êtes
base quand j'étais petit et viella à la
chasse à la pêche comme ça avec votre
père est un jouet sont venus vous voir
pour le parti pêcher à ses traditions et
vous ont embarqué je vous avais pas
compris que c'est un parti vous donc
c'est encore mais bien sûr jean st
gelais enrôler oui tout à fait dit non
je ne participe pas ça c'est vrai que je
défend ses idées afin de valider le fait
de la page
la pêche la chasse la nature chez
quelqu'un d'autre et nature mais hors de
question de ne participer à un parti
politique
et puis dans leur liste de bronze une
des chambres plus à ça près des
électeurs sans doute quoi donc
alors l'état voulait pas en parler le
terrain non ce n'est pas un sujet que
j'ai envie de brel voilà c'est
suffisamment grave et puis du fait de
mon image publique il vaut mieux pas
faire de commentaire parce que ce sera
toujours mal interprétés je vous ai pas
peur je vais pas dire que j'ai peur mais
lorsque je
je vois ce qui est arrivé à mon ami
bixente lizarazu c'est vrai que ça
apporte à réfléchir et je suis surtout
très triste pour lui et j'espère ne
jamais connaître cette situation
est-ce que c'est pas comme un peu la
terreur là c'est à dire que vous pouvez
pas vous exprimer parce que vous avez
peur de représailles sur votre famille
parce qu'ils ne font pas régner la
terreur ben c'est oui oui hier la
terreur il ya la peur je m'exprime et
vont entendre que j'ai une image
publique je préfère ne pas m'exprimer
banderas s'il faisait parler d'eux et
résout et à banderas aussi qui est oui
je sais je savais que ça allait moins
bien
bon alors on continue votre gilet et
fait des études collège catholique à
bayonne astier doué en maths et en
physique et vous dis tu avais pas fait
du foot j'aurais pu le faire de la
gestion et les connaissances que j'avais
certaines facilités
j'ai continué et continue et après par
la suite ni branché du marrakech pour
une compatibilité avec le football alors
pourquoi au pays du rugby faisait choisi
le foot je pense c'est venu
naturellement j'ai joué au rugby aussi
ça me plaisait mais je me sentais plus à
l'aise avec un avec un ballon et puis
parce que mes camarades les plus proches
et jouer au football donc pour rester
avec eux je joue au football aussi vous
commencé très tôt une première licence à
l'âge de 12 ans et tard avant vous
trouvez ça t'a pris par rapport à moi on
va commencer à l'heure actuelle et à 6
en sept ans il semble déjà avant dans
des clubs avec des parents qui les
harcèle au bord du terrain donc attendre
l'âge de 7 ans et parents qui poussent
le papa qui voudrait que c'est
absolument footballeur idée des
éducateurs qui sont pas toujours quand
votre père vous demande pourquoi vous
n'allez pas jouer aux genêts d'anglet
vous dit aucun joueur pendant d'algues
vertes avec 100 votes perdre quand votre
père vous demande pourquoi vous n'avez
pas joué aux genêts d'anglet vite aucun
joueur n'est jamais sorti de la base et
c'est déjà beau chemin motivé parce que
déjà dès le départ vous prenez l'aviron
bayonnais est pas les genêts d'anglet
oui
aujourd'hui parce que souvent vous et
commence à dire anglais ou les
attentions
ça vous allez revenir là bas un très bon
football jeunes aux genêts d'anglet mais
dès le début
voilà dès le début pour viser la
réussite
non je ne sais pas pourquoi je me
rappelle avoir dit ça mais partant pour
moi le football c'était pas c'était pas
un métier je voyais pas ça comme comme
revenir professionnel c'était un jeu
mais bon tant qu'à prendre une licence
et être dans un club où tombent au temps
où aller dans une équipe qui prennent
pas des raclées tous les week-ends
j'aimais pas perdre maintenant qu'à
partir de là je suis dès votre plus
jeune âge vous détestez père vous dit
l'important c'est pas de jouer c'est de
gagner sur vous êtes entier coubertin
oui ça change c'est la doctrine et jouer
pour jouer sur m'intéresse beaucoup à
gagner et du plaisir à travers la
victoire verte
mais comme j'étais petit les gens disent
si tu es ne quand vous perdiez serez
vous parliez pas aux autres leur faisait
la gueule retraite cité caveau rude
comme il dit chez moi saluer la tête en
font donner je fais piquer des crises
non mais insupportable les joueurs
puisque même en fuite
vous avez perdu une finale de coupe
d'aquitaine moi c'est d'être les mini
vous pleuré après déchets ça vous touche
est vraiment horreur de la défaite
faisait des prières pour gagner non
maintenant à faisait à l'époque
après l'arrêté l'arrêté quand votre à la
mort vous aussi
oui j'ai changé un peu de latitude
je suis catholique mais bon je suis pas
pratique je dois un croyant qu avant
vous croyez plus ce destin 4 juin
maintenant ah oui tout à fait bensalah
quoi c'est vrai bon alors ensuite vous
partez en formation à nantes 1 bat
bordeaux
il faut dire que les mecs de bordeaux
obèses et crée coup j'étais venu chez
vos parents en limousine il des cigares
des grosse mallette et en disant à votre
père quand vous voulez pour votre fils
est vrai que c'est pas très élégant dans
l'impressionnant c'est vrai je veux
vendre ou de mac line mais c'est mon
grand père qui disait ça un mini-cd
vraiment kenyans mais ça
donnez tout à fait cette image là quand
on a acheté un un bon petit vous donc le
cochon je regarde le nourrir et puis
n'est pas bon on vient je fais
uniquement bourse après il résida marche
pas après c'est dur quand vous allez à
nantes
et là c'est dur parce que vous retrouvez
à l'âge de 14 ans seule dans cette
grande ville puis en plus ce sont deux
formations j'imagine que d'émulation
c'est la jungle en pleuvait il faut pas
avoir on a une image un peu dorée du
centre de formation puis moi je suis
arrivé j'ai eu la malchance qu'on ait
parlé beaucoup de moi comme est présenté
comme la future star et je suis arrivé à
15 ans il y avait d'autres joueurs entre
15 et 18 ans ils me l'ont fait payer un
petit peu qua non mais bon ça fait quoi
puis j'ai été accepté après c'est comme
ça il faut savoir ce que vous apprenez à
vous dépasser dans tous les cas là bas
et puis au bout d'un moment vous
commencez à prendre des cuites avec eux
ça devient plus sympa non une surtout
mémorable line 104
ah ouais d'accord et puis bon encontre
et marcel desailly oui voilà qui devenu
votre votre compte a mis par la suite
donc c'est sûr alors déjà la base
j'étais capitaine au centre de formation
à vous êtes vraiment un leader né donc
c'est un chef quoi je sais pas où ça
s'est fait naturellement
alors est ce qu'il faut être pour être
chef mais bon partout où je suis passé
on m'a confié des responsabilités dès le
début vous avez été habitué à être en
contact avec la presse et que les médias
de par là même de parler du bon jazz oui
j'étais au devant de la scène donc à
partir de là j'ai très vite compris
comment fonctionnaient les médias un
avantage alors là on arrive à la file 69
non mais c'est une tradition dans cette
émission et les rôles sont inversés
évidemment donc c'est vous qui allez me
poser une question oui j'ai une question
indiscrète j'ai une remarque j'ai
entendu je voudrais savoir si c'est une
légende
est ce que c'est vrai que vous ne portez
nickel sont ni un slip
ouais c'est vrai
mais quels sont les slips y allait
souvent il faut c'est que voilà c'est en
vente libre
on est bien d'autres émissions sont au
ps que deschamps dans leurs champs alors
notre premier match pro avec contre
brest 16 ans et demi vous n'êtes pas
très doué techniquement
non il qu'à nice a tardé c'est ce que
c'est ce que j'ai vu dans tous les
nombreux articles que j'ai lu on dit que
vous n'êtes pas bon dribble pas bon de
la tête
vous avez une frappe qui est pas très
puissante oui elle était au départ
ressenti à face à un certain que ça ça
ne sert pas fiscalement non non je la
préfère des ailes de pigeon et tout ça
dans un tas de trucs votre jean dijon
j'étais pas un surdoué j'ai beaucoup
travaillé mais j'ai pas l'aisance d'un
zidane thierry henry je peux à
l'attaquant qua non non vraiment pas
nous je l'étais quand j'étais jeune je
marquais beaucoup de buts avant rue tout
à l'heure vous avez dit combien de buts
4 en équipe de france en équipe de
france jamais en plus 22 23 24 et dans
toute ma carrière tout le monde
pas spécialement tu ça va moins ça va
plus ça va plus je vais finir derrière
le gardien sera u entraîneur des
gardiens
je peux plus votre génie c'est le
placement donc je vais toujours il faut
être ça ça fait partie de mon jeu mais
bon le football ça choquant même avec
les pieds dedans c'est pour ça que l'on
dit que bon je suis pas très technique
si quand je dois mettre le ballon à
gauche on va toujours à droite
j'ai envoyé des problèmes quand même pas
vous reprocher que j'ai récupéré
beaucoup de ballons que j'en perdais
beaucoup ci avait au fil du temps ça
s'est amélioré mais bon j'arrive quand
même à faire obéir le ballon mais ils se
réfèrent bien sur le terrain je ne vous
ont pas d où c'est lui
on l'amène au stade il faut y aller tous
j'ai une oreillette j'ai une oreillette
gros progrès depuis bref c'est un truc
qu'on apprend dans le bouquin c'est que
vous êtes un sacré de valeur en fait
c'est vrai quand on voit ça ah ouais en
fait votre très bonne heure c'est un
truc sont bien on découvre pas avec les
médias mais un bossu de sava la savane
très particulier je réponds pas des
questions de football donc à vallorbe
avec moi il a pas de danger à 20 ans
vous êtes capitaine de nantes
et alors là même si l'on vous êtes vous
êtes sélectionné pour la première fois
dans les bleus qui sont à l'époque
coachée par platini oui alors platini se
dit un truc sur le comment aller
chercher un trophée moi j'adore cette
histoire ce qui vous a dit il faut
prendre son temps il a raison on m'a dit
beaucoup de choses à dire mais prend le
temps parce que c'est possible que ça
n'est ce pas oui encore ce même plaisir
il a raison mais j'ai eu la chance de
connaître assez souvent quand même mais
bon il faut prendre le plaisir passe et
rennes vraiment un plaisir d'arriver au
bout de gagner une coupe c'est beaucoup
de boulot d'un très bon comme ça et je
trouve c'est vrai que quand on reçoit un
trophée
vous aurez vous aurez votre molière vous
verrez quand on reçoit un trophée on y
va toujours en colère ce matin
oui molière mais 25 ans je n'avais pas
apprécié apprécié chaque pas il faut
savourer bon à part sa bombe tout le
monde vous le dis quoi il a il n'a pas
été très sympa vu platini
c'est ce qu'on me dit mais pourquoi je
sais pas si c'est
moi j'ai de bons rapports avec lui c'est
quelqu'un que je respecte énormément que
j'ai jamais voulu critiquer parce qu'il
n'est pas critiquable pour moi mais bon
pourtant quand je le vois quand il
toujours le sourire devant vous il la
ramène pas non je le chambre mensuels 1
en privé quoi je me gêne pas non plus
mais ça s'arrête là alors il a dit que
j'étais un joueur peu spectaculaire sans
génie pas un grand joueur il est jaloux
parce qu'il n'a jamais eu la coupe du
monde mais je suis demandée j'espère pas
si l'année à être jaloux platini par
rapport à tout ce qu'il a fait d'autres
joueurs qu'ils soient aigris et jaloux
je peux le comprendre sans citer de nom
n'est que michel platini sur comme ça
non pour moi c'est vous que vous en
pensez que c'est étudié le problème
pendant de longs mois
jalousie le sait dominique rocher
d'accord avec moi bon après vous est
vendu à l'om orge adore le toujours le
côté maquignons et ils vous disent ils
vous disent alors du bliss on a vendu
didier ce sera marseille j'avais besoin
d'argent l'époque il était en difficulté
je serai le président le regretté max
bouyer et il m'a appris ça oui on sort
d'un match en équipe de france je joue à
toulouse vendus voilà on va vous arriver
à marseille au tapis alors lui en plus
ils croient pas sur des par bribes on
vous a prêté à bordeaux
oui après six mois après parce que j'ai
eu un départ fulgurant et après un peu
le trou noir était prêt il était vendu à
marseille marseille le prêt de bordeaux
l'endroit objet réel c'est après qu'ils
voulaient pas que je revienne ouais
c'est sûr bien sûr quand vous revenez me
wade s'est prêté il lui dit chez moi tu
réussiras pas vaut mieux que tu partes
sympa comme mec c'est ce qu'il pensait
c'est bizarre il n'est pas donné pas vu
si puisque humains après quand il m'a il
m'a donné ma chance
ouais c'est qu'au fond de lui et vous
êtes battus j'ai discuté avec lui
pendant une heure et demie je me suis
accrochée et accrochée jeudi parce que
pour moi à partir du moment où j'avais
signé un contrat l'om
il est hors de question il fallait que
je me pose alors sur sas était clair et
donc je suis revenu puis mais a pris
mais il m'a facilité la tâche quand même
il m'a donné ma chance
après vous imposer que desailly
d'ailleurs et puis vous finissez capital
qu'après la coupe d'europe des clubs
champions à munich
jusque là tout va bien d'après les oem
verra évidemment là c'est moins drôle ça
c'est donc grâce à un petit peu si
c'était moi j'étais au milieu
parlementaire et l'argent ben quand même
vu à et puis l'histoire de la coupe du
monde 94 oui moi j'étais au parc des
princes moi si on mettait les manteaux
bien ce moment là qu'il y ait eu le
temps de partir un piètre état et les
billets pour les aider à mieux le ballon
et c'était cosson 10 nov là bas c'est
super il y avait des gens qui étaient
pas en bleu blanc rouge qu'on sait que
ses larmes qui coulaient sur le bleu
blanc rouge et où c'est une image d'une
force c'est terrible pour vous un pour
nous joueurs c'est un sané traoré
matisse mais ça restera un point noir de
ma carrière que ce sont dix neuf [ __ ]
suis là et là comme par hasard c'est bon
on peut pas aller plus bas donc c'est le
début de la remontée avec avec jacques
est oui alors d'abord ces cantonales
capitaine des bleus 1 jusqu'à que salle
palas que ce qu'il fasse et ses bêtises
oui c'est possible je sais qu'il faut si
vous avez bien non je sais qu'il a fait
des bêtises mais si on parlait je sais
que vous l'appréciez beaucoup de brevets
bien sûr comme footballeur comme être
humain comme acteur il a fait des arrêts
il laisse pas indifférent quand même eu
des mois que cantona pour moi j'aime
bien commun que mac sont bons alors
jacques et apprécié votre charisme vous
remplacez donc content là disons qu'il a
eu des discussions avec eric cantona il
avait des choix à faire et à partir du
moment où
il n'a pas prié rick il a dû s'appuyer
sur un sur une autre personne il a fait
le tour on peut d anciens et puis m'a
confié le brassard de capitaine mais
nous a raconté qu'on retient c'est que
quand jacques y est allé voir en
angleterre il était dans une fête il a
fait attendre jacquet pendant deux
heures bon ben voilà révèle idan
djorkaeff remplace quant au napa pas sur
l'euro 96 et la grande équipe de france
selon ses explications
ouais et non pas le fait que je sois mon
capitaine ouais quand on n'a pas bouclé
ses dires est quand même non ah non j'ai
pas ce pouvoir là lorsque cantona et
vous autres était de porter doucement
oui j'ai pensé l'eau pour lui pendant
cinq ans donc c'est pas
et puis voilà et on arrive à l'été 98 ya
ça m'amènerait rj